after nearly two weeks on the run the
final two palestinian prisoners were
caught overnight israel said two other
people who had helped them were also
detained from a house in jenin
elsewhere in the palestinian town
confrontations after a separate israeli
incursion apparently designed as a decoy
tonight we have closure the last two
terrorists who escaped gilboa prison two
weeks ago were arrested
muna del nifayat and ayam kamamji both
members of palestinian islamic jihad
gave themselves up after israeli forces
surrounded the house they were hiding in
kamamji's father says his son called him
first saying he was surrendering to
prevent harm to anyone else
two weeks have passed and i had expected
him to call me from gaza or lebanon or
some safe place
behold the israeli occupation force is
fully responsible for his life for his
safety and well-being
for some days there had been israeli
reports that the net was closing in on
janine the final target the home of
ahmed abu jafar his son was one of those
arrested on suspicion of helping the
escapees
i was here when i heard gunshots i
didn't know where they came from i went
inside and closed the door later i had
soldiers on loudspeakers saying turn
yourselves in or we demolish the house
there were concerns that a shootout in
which either or both prisoners were
killed could have triggered a wider
round of violence
the events in the early hours of sunday
morning here at this house brought to an
end an enormous scale israeli manhunt
without the kind of violence that many
had feared nonetheless this entire
chapter has been a major embarrassment
to the israeli security apparatus
the prisoners have told their lawyers
that they were able to dig steadily for
months through their cell floor into
void space under the high-security
gilboa facility despite the fact that a
previous such attempt had been
discovered and security tightened
the escape itself was a serious mistake
intelligence operational and systematic
wise but from the moment there was a
malfunction first of all banded together
together in the first stage against the
enemy in order to restore deterrence and
then to fix internally what was needed
and there are things to fix
while israelis celebrate the recapture
of all six escapees palestinians remain
focused on the escape seen as a rare
fleeting victory for a population among
whom solidarity with prisoners is a near
consensus issue harry fawcett al-jazeera
janine in the occupied west bank